[Música]
y
esta mañana no se trata de un paseo
común y corriente para regímenes ni con
su perro flibuste están buscando en
champiñón de lujo cuyo sobrenombre es el
diamante negro
aquí donde estaba trufa aquí
aquí sí sí sí estamos en el período de
la búsqueda de la trufa no se lo
encuentra es la trufa me gusta
tiene 8 años y desde temprana edad
entendió que debía ayudar a su amo a
encontrar el famoso champiñón en este
terreno es 6 hectáreas de roble verde
siempre se la muestro al perro has visto
lo que encontraste y entonces por
supuesto de inmediato la recompensa el
contrario de lo que piensa un terreno
como este no es sólo plantar un árbol y
esperar es plantar un árbol y trabajar
durante todo un año y entonces las
temporadas que al cuarto año encontramos
algunas trufas debajo de algunos árboles
pero para tener una producción
interesante deben pasar unos diez o doce
años
actualmente francia produce cerca de la
mitad de las 120 toneladas que son
comercializadas en el mundo la famosa
melanosporum
90% de esta producción proviene de
robles criados en viveros
por planta joven ponemos un gramo y
medio de trufa parece poco pero hay que
saber que un gramo es un millón y medio
de esporas es bastante una pequeña
maceta como este nosotros quiero decir
nuestro vivero y representa 80 kilos de
trufa para poder hacer los sembrados
para cosechar las trufas hay que armarse
de paciencia
porque el adiestramiento de los perros
es un arte sutil y delicado
[Música]
al cúmulo de muestras de perro salchicha
más bien disipado aún en formación
busca buscar
muy bien
damos recompensa de inmediato porque el
perro debe asociar la recompensa al
gesto si se le deja tres o cuatro
segundos de reflexión tiene tiempo para
pensar en otra cosa y no sabe que fue
recompensada por haber encontrado la
trufa y si una mariposa vuela se dice
que fue recompensado porque vio volar a
una mariposa entonces en cuanto
encuentra se le recompensa un puede
reforzar la búsqueda
sí muy bien
el perro trabaja por amor a su amo un
perro de caza caza por instinto su amo
es secundario mientras que la trufa no
representa ningún interés para el perro
el único interés es darle gusto a su amo
entonces hay que haber establecido
cierta complicidad
luego el amo toma el relevo
esto es como las trufas
no se hace en unos días
y dije busca busca
en promedio un perro se toma un año para
asimilar un buen método
jueves en la mañana en ops en bar es el
día del mercado de trufas difícil no ver
el puesto de philip de sutiss el
productor de trufas más hablador
en papel periódico en papel de cocina
sin lavarlas en un recipiente en la
nevera en el frío a la trufa le gusta el
frío antes de comerse la lava de agua
fría luego las pone en la nevera durante
dos horas y cuando se le pregunta dónde
encontrar las mejores trufas luego la
pasión que ha bateado el gusto depende
de la tierra no es necesario hablar de
departamentos a cincuenta metros la
trufa no sabe igual
me pone por favor 100 gramos de café
este año no hay muchas trufas el precio
ha aumentado el kilo todas solo se las
elijo y se las cortó le doy trufas de la
mejor calidad eso es lo que hace la
diferencia de precio le pongo el peso
correcto pero los aficionados están
dispuestos a pagar una trufa no es más
costosa que un buen pedazo de carne
porque no comemos 500 gramos sólo un
poco y saben el rico
y ahora
tras la venta a los particulares y a los
chefs de los restaurantes de la región
philip de sutiss guarda algunas trufas
para el restaurante de su yerno
[Música]
es perfecta mide su madurez es negra es
magnífica tiene todo lo que buscamos en
una trufa de temporada
porque aquí la trufa está en todas
partes en el capuchino de boletos en el
capellán de foca
en las hazañas y aún más insólito en el
postre gestionada en carne líquida
prepare un caramelo líquido y agregue
las trufas al último momento puede
sorprender porque de costumbre la que
entera está acostumbrada a la trufa en
los platos salados las pastas es lo más
frecuente entonces es original tener
trufas en el postre pero funciona muy
bien en cualquier otro producto basta
con la cantidad correcta y se puede usar
con todo tipo de cocina por 85 euros los
golosos degustan 130 gramos de trufas
repartidas en distintos platos
es muy refinado muy rico me encanta es
la primera vez que tomamos una comida
con trufas excelente
desde la tierra al plato la trufa tiene
su temporada se degusta desde noviembre
hasta finales de marzo
[Música]
dice